this video is sponsored by manscaped.com
but more on that in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
petro's victory in colombia gabrielle
borick's government in chile the
possible return of lula in brazil and
the arrival of pedro castillo to power
in peru latin america is once again
immersed in a huge wave of political
change a change that clearly bets on the
resurgence of left-wing parties and
politicians a new left apparently much
less radical and much more social
democratic than the one we knew as the
so-called socialism of the 21st century
but what if i told you that we could
find a tiny exception a small one among
giants that is turning the other way and
aspires to become a model for the future
argentina do you know what country i am
referring to in this case i'm referring
to uruguay
the success of a ruler is not measured
in the reflection of a mirror it is
measured in the reflection of each one
of the uruguayans and the people who
live in the country if people look at
themselves in the mirror when our
government term ends and are freer the
government is successful if not we will
have failed for me fundamentally louis
la cal-pou president of uruguay the
story we are looking at today began on
the sunday the 27th of october 2019. on
that day as happens every five years
presidential elections took place in
uruguay and we are not talking about
just any elections for the first time in
15 years there was an alternation in
power on that day the frente amplio the
leftist coalition that had been
governing uruguay since 2004 was
defeated and defeat that in all fairness
was by a narrow a very narrow margin
you see after coming in second and a
long way behind the frente and pleo in
the first round and with the memory of
the second round and defeat of his
father in 2009 and of himself in 2014
lakaye powell finally won power by a
very narrow margin of little more than a
point and a half a mere 37 000 votes was
enough to turn uruguayan politics upside
down
[Music]
now what made uruguayan voters decide to
go for a lack eye po where did this 180
degree turn around happen what does it
mean in the latin american political
context and the most important question
of all more than enough time has passed
since the election so the question we're
all wondering is how has uruguay changed
since then well we want to find out so
let's get cracking
the new popular mandate
what brought lakaye powell to power
after 15 years of political domination
by the frente amplio what exactly did
the current president of uruguay come up
against well visualpolitik fans in order
to answer this question we have to go
back to 2019 at that time we can
highlight three major issues that
concerned and even threatened the future
of the country first of all there is the
issue of security you see uruguay has
always been a relatively safe country
but that all began to change in 2011. in
the following eight years the homicide
rate practically doubled and something
that had never been a noteworthy concern
security began to become one of the key
issues on the political agenda the
situation was getting so bad that some
sectors even began to call for the armed
forces to take control of internal
security to the detriment of the police
lack of security the issue that worries
uruguay the most ahead of the elections
concern over record increases in murders
and violent robberies in uruguay
homicides grew by 45.8 percent and
violent robberies by 53.5 percent in the
last year but that was not all secondly
after 15 years of the french and polio's
redistributed policies the economy was
exhausted practically kaput
[Music]
[Applause]
for example uruguay's economic growth
went from 4.6 in 2013 to zero growth in
2019 poverty had begun to grow and the
public deficit had soared to almost five
percent of gdp one of the biggest budget
slippages in uruguay's entire history to
top it off increasing regulations and
ever more government intervention caused
the country to fall back to 101st place
in the world bank's doing business
ranking
in other words the fear that the
argentine disease would take its toll on
the country was more real than ever and
finally we have one of the most common
epidemics in all of hispanic countries
corruption
[Music]
to give you an idea the vice president
of the country himself raul sandik was
accused of corruption accusations for
which he was ultimately convicted in
2021 lack of security economic
stagnation and corruption three
ingredients that together spell one
outcome institutional degradation yes in
2019 uruguay was one of the best
countries in latin america in economic
political and social terms but things
were simply not going in the right
direction and right at that point lakaye
poe appeared with a very clear message
to make a 180 degree turn in the
country's policies and my visualpolitik
fans that was none other than the reason
he allowed him to defeat the frente and
pleo the promise of building a new
uruguay
of course it's one thing to win
elections and quite another to have a
blank check the small margin with which
it won the elections has forced the
government to depend on a complex
five-party alliance in order to achieve
a majority in congress both in the house
of representatives and in the senate it
is known as the multi-color coalition of
course you can imagine that behind the
name keeping five parties united is not
always an easy task and of course it's
something that forces you to keep
everyone happy in other words to agree
on any reform requires a lot of dialogue
and negotiation to top it all off coming
to power in 2019 and suffering a
pandemic in 2020 that's uh how should i
put this it's a real pain in the ass you
come to power and before long your
political and economic priorities have
changed completely all in all la kaya
pau's government has managed to
introduce important changes in the
country these changes are radically
different from what is being done in
practically all the countries in the
region and in some cases may end up
provoking an enormous political clash
with neighboring countries do you want
to know what we are talking about and
how the land of the charua is changing
of course you do so let's get started
but before we get to that there comes a
time in a man's life when he has to
shave down there and believe me when
that moment comes i do not recommend
using a regular razor a friend of mine
tried that and now we call him uno
that's all i can say in other words
there is only one realistic option for
trimming below the waist and that's
manscaped this is the performance
package by manscaped an all-in-one
starter kit for body hair grooming and
hygiene included in the package is the
marvelous lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer
with its unique skin safe technology it
helps prevent nicks and cuts and don't
worry i'm not going to give you a
demonstration in front of the camera
since this trimmer is both cordless and
waterproof you can use it in the shower
or run it under the sink to prevent any
messy cleanup and the razer even has a
little built-in led light that helps us
to see better and all the little nukes
and grannies and it even has a travel
log for when you go traveling but that's
not all in addition to this razor the
man's cave performance package includes
an epilator for nose hairs the so called
weed whacker and two deodorants designed
for the male crotch the corrupt
preserver and the crop reviver now that
summer is coming they'll come in
especially handy as always we have a
very special discount for all of you who
follow visualpolitik basically if you
use the code vpn you will get a 20
discount plus free international
shipping so wherever you are you can get
manscaped plus a free pair of boxer
briefs and a free toiletry bag remember
folks manscaped the perfect tools for
your family jewels and now let's get
back to the video
rebuild uruguay
pay close attention to the following
news item
uruguay bahamas and portugal the chosen
countries by argentines for their tax
benefits obviously uruguay is far from
being a tax haven but it does have much
better conditions than argentina
especially if the income comes from
abroad and above all what has improved
are the prospects for the future which
is particularly important when you want
to put your savings aside for safe
keeping don't you think and of course
things like this help a lot
uruguay approved tax vacations for 10
years for foreigners obtaining residency
more benefits in uruguay
approved a tax relaxation for companies
that settle and invest in that country
however of all the reform processes that
the uruguayan government has implemented
in recent years there is one that stands
out above all the rest
[Music]
i am referring of course to the law of
urgent consideration luc for those in
the know we are talking about a very
long law with 476 articles that deals
with all kinds of issues from the
economy to education including
communication services it is the
government's great transformation
project and take note because after its
approval an appeal made by the frente
amplio meant that a large part of the
changes had to be submitted to a
referendum and once again the uruguayans
again by a narrow margin of just two
points voted in favor of the reforms
the uruguayan executives come out
strengthened after a referendum that
keeps the country divided
uruguay with a narrow margin the
government wins a key referendum for its
administration by only 22 000 votes the
majority of uruguayans backed the option
not to repeal 135 of 476 articles of the
so-called law of urgent consideration
luke promoted by president luis la
cal-pou now what exactly does this luc
say what are its most salient changes
well among the other reforms that we can
talk about the main ones we can find are
[Music]
in economic matters a ceiling has been
set on growth of public spending and a
limit on the level of debt as well as
the creation of a fiscal council to
evaluate the different public spending
projects and try to avoid political
waste secondly in labor matters from now
on when a strike date occurs the right
of employers and employees to work if
they so wish will be expressly
recognized until now even if a worker
did not want to join a strike the
so-called passive freedom of association
of 2006 could prevent him or her from
working on that day among the same lines
the luc also declares pickets that
impede the free movement of people goods
or services both in public and private
spaces to be illegitimate and illegal in
other words you can go on strike but you
cannot force others to go on strike nor
can you stop the
country then in terms of security the
law broadens the circumstances and
places in which both civilians and
police can resort to self-defense and in
terms of housing a new voluntary rental
regime is introduced that reduces the
rights of tenants this regime recognizes
for example faster evictions in cases of
non-payment the idea is that more
landlords will put their properties on
the market and this will somehow bring
down prices
well these are just some of the many
changes with with the lackier power
government that want to turn to the
tight in uruguay and the next step seems
to be the tricky reform of social
security after a commission of experts
in 2020 will confirm what is already an
open secret with the aging of the
population the public social security
system as it is set up in uruguay is
unviable to give you an idea social
security expenditure in uruguay is
similar to that of spain and even higher
than that of wealthy countries such as
denmark or norway so it's time to get
down to work anyway with all we've seen
what do you want me to say you may take
or leave the current uruguayan
government but visualpolitik fans i
think one thing is clear they are
nothing like what is happening in the
rest of latin america but wait a moment
we are not finished yet another key
fundamental and completely disruptive
bet of this government has a lot to do
with foreign policy and especially to do
with microsewer we are talking about a
gamble that may end up doing no less
than making montevideo send buenos aires
and brasilia to hell check this out
[Music]
a new pathway to the world
take a look at this statement of intent
my duty as a uruguayan is to ask the
world to open up to me because if you
open up the world to us we will walk
safely luis la cal-pou president of
uruguay visual politic viewers since his
arrival to power powe has understood
that above all there is something that
does not work in this region of the
world something we have told you about
many times here on visualpolitik the
import substitution policy and the
rampant protectionism that characterizes
these countries so no sooner said than
done to argentina's great annoyance
you'll understand why later the new
government of uruguay was faced with
three important foreign policy
challenges as soon as it came to power
firstly to make it more pro-market
secondly to contribute to making
mkrossor more flexible and thirdly to
facilitate the arrival of more foreign
direct investment in the country well
that and also to put all populist
chieftains in the region on the same
footing that is clearly condemning the
regimes of cuba nicaragua and venezuela
but let's not get sidetracked let's
focus on what has been the uruguayan
government's big gamble in foreign
affairs take a look at this
uruguay needs to open up to the world if
they accompany us fine if not we go
alone luis la cal pou president of
uruguay
on mercosur we are in the boat we have
to think about who is in the cargo we
want to move forward and we are going to
do it in uruguay we are trying to
negotiate with china turkey with the
united kingdom luis la cal pou president
of uruguay so it's crystal clear the
current uruguayan government is clear
that in order to secure more investment
and better economic growth the country
has to open up to the world the problem
is that at the same time it wants to
negotiate new trade agreements uruguay
belongs to macrosor and this limits its
room for maneuver which explains news
like this one
uruguay's rebelliousness strains
mercosur to the maximum we have also
told you here on visualpolitik the
southern common market microsoft does
not work at least not as it should this
institution was supposed to promote
trade in south america however with a
common external tariff that more than
doubles the global average and certain
limitations when negotiating with third
countries so in practice this agreement
works more like a protectionist barrier
for this reason the lakaye poe
government has launched a political war
to make the block more flexible reduce
the common external tariff and allow
member countries to negotiate trade
agreements with third countries on their
own this is something that macrocer's
current regulations prevent
[Music]
of course so far the results have not at
all been positive buenos aires above all
continues to insist that this block be
what it is today a sort of closed box
that instead of encouraging trade slows
it down well you understand by now the
aversion argentine politicians have to
free trade and globalization the lack of
real interest in moving forward with the
free trade agreement with the european
union is a good example of this now the
point is that uruguay is close to
signing a free trade agreement with
china and probably with other countries
as well and china alone already weighs
more in uruguay's escort basket than its
microsoft neighbours does this mean that
the land of the tradua could end up
leaving mecca it doesn't seem that
straightforward because its block
partners still dominate imports but if
things continue like this in the future
it would not be out of the question the
world is much bigger than metro sewer in
fact since 2019 the weight of exports
and gdp that had been falling since 2014
has started to grow again and in 2021
although the external balance remained
negative had its second lowest level of
the last 12 years it was only improved
by the extraordinary figure of the 2020s
when the imports collapsed due to the
pandemic
and what does all this mean well it is
not just a simple stubbornness of the
president the foreign market is very
very much in uruguay's favor in fact
exports soared in 2021 and are doing the
same in 2022. now the global food crisis
triggered by russia's invasion of
ukraine promises to boost exports even
further and if posed plans come to
fruition it is clear that the foreign
sector will play a key role in uruguay's
economic future and so there you have it
ultimately despite the pandemic the
economy has improved unemployment is
about to break its most positive record
in seven years poverty is contracting
and crime is down substantially
much remains to be done but the data is
clear today things in uruguay seem to be
on the right track or at least on a
better path than they were on in 2019
and that in a region full of problems is
a breath of fresh air this perhaps
explains why uruguay is practically the
only exception to the shift of the left
that is taking place throughout latin
america the question now is can the
reforms promoted by the pau government
become a model for countries such as
argentina how far will the changes
promoted by the current president of
uruguay go will uruguayans re-evaluate
this reform path in the 2024 elections
these are the questions and in this case
the answers are over to you if you like
leave us your impression in the comments
and let's open a friendly debate and as
always if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik once again thank you very
much for watching and i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you